thank you thanks everybody it was a very
inspiring morning session so here I will
top talk about business model analysis
it's more of an application talk and the
work been doing for may be many many
years starting in Microsoft Research I
continued that work at ebay research and
then some of the work now I'm putting in
practice as a part of this company I
found it farrah we talk more about
farrah later so a lot of co-authors
especially I'd like to thank Steve
Daedalus I have many many discussions
with him on various many things so let's
see so business model knowledge is so
people know like business models are
important so this is when quote used to
be served in fountain they change it
bottle and that's a basically a big jump
for them now it's one of the biggest
branch now so note that it's not just a
business model it's also the user
experience which was changed the places
which you can consume coke the way you
can consume coke is change so a good
business model aligns well armed with a
user experience so this is typically
like a innovation pyramid in companies
like you have to do day-to-day operation
that's most important most of your
people are here then of course
technology you need to keep improving
your processes your products that's next
but these two itself is not what solves
the customer the customer cares about
user experience how they are going to
experience our product and to have a
best user experience you need to make
money so these two things go hand in
hand so there it has to be tight
integration between business models and
user experiences okay so another thing
is how many of you know play for sure
you know that's what I expected so play
for sure is was Microsoft Technology in
competition with iTunes this was started
in early 2000 2001 maybe and nobody
knows about it it was a bad business
model it was basically like a business
more which was also suggested by a top
name economists who came and gave talks
to microsoft executives it was a
two-sided business model where one side
will be all the music sellers all the
websites which sells music and the other
side will be all the hardware players
who make like Samsung Sony so they make
hardware players as long as you buy a
song from from a participants of play
for show technology you can play it on
aim on a play for short hardware so it
was a very good strong network effect
the problem here is is the user
experience it has to compromise the user
experience a lot the difference between
a computer which is also another
two-sided market is that only computer
situating machine you can come up with
every day new and new user experiences
so so it makes sense that both sides are
Richard but if music player only plays
music so was it sort of a bad
interaction between user experience in
business model sorry chads how many you
know search ads so one person no search
ads on the other hand this is a this is
a example of a very good alignment of
user experience in business model on
Google you go and what is the user
experience click and go to another
website what is the business model click
and go to another website it just the
backend how when is paid and one is free
which changes but it's a very good
alignment and and you can see that huge
company built around this so one
question people ask 80 watch the
difference between business model and
let's say pricing the difference is the
pricing is about how much to charge for
an event
we're business models to come up with
what even to charge with how do you
actually make money okay so given what
we have a connectivity all the time and
all the technology all the sensors are
the everything now we have a choice of
multitude of business model
traditionally before all this smartphone
etc they were like handful of business
model are you going to rent are you
selling and all the same full of
business models but now you can have a
lot of things like cost-per-click
without technology such a business model
was not possible the challenge for us is
be it's very hard you predict a friend
which business will be good with
business model would be bad it's more of
a art so people get to know oh yeah i
know it's obvious after it has been
proven successful after it has been
proven failure so you don't have a lot
of data to analyze those business models
and even mathematical tools are probably
not sufficient so what are what are the
ingredients if I am trying to like if I
analyze business models so what are the
ingredients which goes in one is the
risk so this actually plays two ways so
its first of all it makes the complexity
so if I am a common user ID if you offer
me a risky proposition I don't know how
to handle it so it will be a bad
business for example well if ebay what
you charge per click and I have to sell
sell one computer that's all I have then
I am taking huge risks i might get 10
clicks built for 10 clicks and then my
problem is is still in hand so people
whenever there is a risk it becomes a
complicated thing now the other thing i
already talked about the user experience
the decision-making must be very easy in
in any kind of good business model so
there are other ingredients one can you
study like certain psychological by
cases people have rent versus own given
the same equal value proposition people
usually prefer owning it there are other
things you can study in business models
like government regulations many of them
are outdated for the internet world so
one can actually use the arbitrage there
now so let me give you one toy example
first this is a work done at microsoft
research with nickel Enns when so
there's this serve highway this is not
more popular in business ma'am and
experience in many places called hot
lanes where you they they paid lane and
a free lane on a highway the free is
whatever the traffic is you can just
travel on the page lane is you have to
pay for it and the amount the charge
changes almost hourly basis depending
upon how much the traffic is now making
you are a driver and you see that oh
it's flashing sometimes like 75 seven
sometime flashing like six dollars how
do you make a decision is it is it a
good pie to travel on a 75 cents maybe
not because the three-lane itself is
flowing very well is it a good buy if
it's a built-up it's six dollars
flashing for use it for a couple of
miles bomb actually it's very hard for
most our drivers to make a good decision
in the current user experience on the
other hand if let's say they were to
implement a pay-for-performance business
model they say that our highways toll
lanes applied six dollars in our very
low money so they could say if you
believe your time is more than six
dollars an hour what use the toll lane
if your current time is worth less than
six dollars an hour use the free lane
and at the end of the when you start
using the toll lane and when you come
out of it we can measure how much time
you saved and just build it accordingly
if you save 15 minutes so this paper
actually come up from a friend
experience was driving on the highway
and he took the toll lane
the free lands were jam-packed but after
a mild even the toll Lane was jam-packed
he paid that dollar 25 he said damn I
mean if I knew I based it dollar
twenty-five I said you'd say that you
drive 1 mile but in that one might you
probably jumped through 500 cards and
may have saved like 20 minutes oh so
that kind of this is making you can sort
by good business models because
everybody knows the itune it was a flat
fee when you started still there are
like two three different fees sure I
don't know what toll road you are
talking about but there is a torrid like
this from jerusalem to tel aviv mm-hmm
that that the engine speed varies and
it's flashes above this and as best I
understand from my Israeli friends it's
super popular they like it so they view
the current version is that you know
it's simple there's a number there and
you make a decision and if it's your
there's a good experience I don't know
why what evidence here they it's not a
good experience first of all iam it
sounds expensive so I gave you one
example like you can see the sub
optimality there you see the toll lane
completely free getting wasted and the
free lanes are all jam-packed this is
you can see all the time so the it is
parallel lens free and told side by side
and you can just observe it and then
yeah so maybe at some places it's a good
thing for a semester and my friends
thought that it was a wonderful
invention for enough money you can go in
the normal speed now you can't decide
it's not a good invention but I think
saying that it's not a good experience
now I'm not saying good experience it's
it's it's better experience than all
being free but there could be a better
experience that's what I'm saying the
decision making is even easier here if
we want to pay for performance people
would not have regret after using it and
many times people do have regret oh I
wish I wasn't old lane because they
realized too late that the free line is
so jam-packed and vice versa so the
equilibrium czar different here and
better
so this we already know so let me go
through the things we can talk about
maybe not all of it so there are some of
the business model these companies use
ebay uses the commission model ten
percent fee of whatever you make on ebay
Google is cost per click then best buy
is a markup model where they get the
inventory from the suppliers and then
mark up the prices and then sell it that
prices and costco is interesting one
they essentially make profit when you
sign up for the membership fee and after
that they try to make between zero to
two percent on the goods they sell so
it's essentially you can say their
profitability is membership fee and
after that you just try to break even so
farrah it's a home transaction platform
so I will come to that last if the time
permits so let me give you a model of
all these business model how do we
compare where the Google business model
is better in which situation whether I
based business model is better but the
costco business model is better in what
situation so let me take a model of
intermediary so this is an intermediary
on one side they have suppliers they are
different in different context in in the
context of ebay these are the sellers in
the context of costco etc these are the
manufacturers of the goods or brands of
the goods in context of google its
advertisers and then we have a buyer so
these supplies are competing for this
buyers pocket but these what we are not
modeling here that bias in some
situation buyers can be competing with
each other like if example heat the
auction so i am not counting that model
here so this is the only the posted
price model okay it turns out this model
you can now use it for various situation
in walmart you can use it so what the
role of intermediary is to facilitate a
match between buyer and sellers that's
what it's trying to do
in various context and and what we saw
as they have they usually have a shelf
available where they put their products
okay this shelf could be hardware shelf
a real sharp like in your at walmart and
it could be a virtual shelf for example
right hand side column on google that's
a shelf usually you have basically the
shelf I have a different sort of
attention if you think about it so at
let's say if i go to walmart it's known
that things that the shoulder heights
are most common things that the bottom
shelf they're less common and for a
short person like me something on the
top shelf as if it doesn't even exist
okay so so you have basically different
resources so this is the shelf for ebay
google walmart and how do we compared to
businesses business model sorry so ebay
which has a commission model would it be
better for ebates let's do to accurately
certain segments of the market for
should it offer cost per click model if
it were to do so would it be good or bad
okay so what we do is it's hard to
experiment such things but we can
mathematically try to analyze their
fundamental properties so as I said the
differences we will drive more theorems
about it but differences the cost per
click is high risk for the advertisers I
will not sell this computer on google
because i don't want to pay per click
price okay commission is loaded it's
very easy to sign up a sign up if you
don't sell anything don't worry there is
no fee so it's easier the primary
difference when the risk comes is is the
cost per click model is the cost of a
click is very similar to some costs when
it click has happened and the user is on
your website
at that point whether you make whether
you're selling properties ten percent
fifty percent twenty percent you have
paid that money so you want to maximize
your transaction probability where
Commission is a sort of a variable cost
because if you do not close the sale you
didn't have to pay any Commission and as
it turns out the the Commission actually
shows up in the consumer prices and then
the price it actually goes up on ebay
voices if it was the cost per click so
it's a mathematical proof so if we were
a particle if this is some demand graph
you will be charging this price and if
it were a submission model you will be
charging slightly higher prices and all
three parties are actually just like
divorce off the buyers get to buy
expensive and the sellers actually have
a lower surplus let me give you a lesson
mathematical proof let me give you an
illustration so let's say you can see
how old my slide is if I think the
popular one is at six these days but I
have a screen shot fires for let me give
an example like how the how these
dynamics good let's say there is a cell
phone its procurement costs for the
seller is for fifty dollars assume
demand curve is linear a thousand
dollars nobody will buy it but at zero
everybody wants one of it okay and it's
linear in between let's say fee-based
charging ten percent commission you can
compute that the optimal price the
seller will it sell will be seven fifty
dollars then because it is a linear
demand curve twenty-five percent of the
bias will purchase it so ebay will make
seventy five dollars per transaction and
on each view it will make $18
seventy-five cents because twenty-five
percent of these times the transaction
will happen seller will made 225 per
transaction but only in each click basis
only 56 dollar twenty-five cents if if I
were to switch its model too
per click that means when you click and
see the beauty description of the cell
phone you go to the sellers page on ebay
you pay a click price but you don't pay
any Commission's afterwards whether you
convert or not it's a our problem so
then the optimal price for the same miss
phone will be seven twenty-five dollars
slightly more buyers will purchase it
because it's cheaper I normalized the
number so that i kept the one thing eBay
is still making 1875 and the seller is
making slightly more profit for each
click so the biggest difference happens
as you can see is the consumer prices so
whenever you have a commission model a
part of that price goes to D to the
buyer and here are these example
screenshot this is the watch on eBay the
cost is 2000 195 the same watch on the
sellers own website is 1895 ok so this
error is essentially transferring all
the all the commission of ebay back to
the buyer now what happens when you see
this so I did they experiment together
with some of my interns I think one was
from Berkeley the debunk we looked at
all the high-end watch others because
there was so there was whatever the
number of we can actually manually see
each of them call each of them and all
those things the watch seller of
high-end who have their website or a
physical shop ok who have a website or
physical shop we're putting a lot of
watches on ebay but selling almost zero
because there is an interest between
both buyer and sellers to go off ebay
and and and do the transaction so now
they are basically we saw that in a in a
commission model consumer prices are
higher what it means is that it now
encourages people to do the transaction
outside of the platform okay when people
are doing projection outside of the
platform the third implication is that
ebay will try to protect that thing by
lowering the fee the pricing structure
would be lower because the the lower the
fee ebay charges the lesser the
incentive for people to go outside of
platform is so when ebay would do all
these data and also use etc they will
say our fees should be lower whereas the
fault is could be in certain categories
is that the business model side okay
they mean and this happens on Amazon to
let me skip
so you can analyzer similarly between
costco let's say and best buy these two
models costco is a membership model best
buy is a markup model one problem which
best buy has to deal with the people go
and view the products on on cost us our
best buy and then go and buy it online
maybe at amazon okay now so I'm imagine
like the Fallen sit when let's say eBay
oh sorry but best buy and sony are
negotiating the price of a sony TV
wholesale price the supplier spice and
costco and Sonja are negotiating and
let's say for conceptually both have
this same number of volume let's say
costco sells million tvs a month and
best buy sells a million TV a month now
the conceptually who is going to get a
better price from the supplier would it
be costco would it be best buy or would
they get the same price because there's
same Z the same number of TV selling any
volunteer or cases so it turns out that
the costco will get better price from
the supplier so
it was due to basically a cusp of ipod
costco have a higher bargaining power
because if best buy stops putting sony
TV on its shelf if the let's say you
have to analyze the break-up point and
if they fail it deals between best buy
and sony the what is the break-up point
if best buy doesn't put sony TV on a
shelf there will be some number of users
who really wants only TV they will go to
probably fries okay let's say there was
a million maybe 700 people will go to
frys and buy sony TV 200 people will buy
maybe depends on it giving 100,000
people decide not to upgrade their TV at
this point so on the other hand costco
charge is a membership fee it is the
only end as a user you are unlikely to
be paying participating in two different
clubs you may not be paying membership
fee to costco as well as sam's club and
you are getting a better deal at costco
so when costco stops keeping the sony TV
the shift from sony to Panasonic will be
much higher then in the in the case of
the best by breaking the deal because
costco is probably the only source of
cheap sony TV that has an implication
for amazon prime so many people say that
amazon prime is actually losing money
people analyze all these but if you
account don't account for the number two
you will analyzing amazon prime
incorrectly because amazon is getting
better bargaining power there are people
now who participate in amazon prime they
don't shop anywhere else so if amazon
prime doesn't have this product you will
buy something else and that gives a
tremendous bargaining power to amazon
and and that reflects in in there
dealing with how they deal with their
suppliers now let me come to the second
part of my talk in next 10 minutes this
is about home transactions that's this
company farah does so it's a
online platform for helping people buy
and sell their homes and we use several
of the economic principle I learned from
people in this room here so the question
we were asking is when we started this
company why is home transactions still
stuck in 20th century even the uber is
taking taxi rides into the 21st century
there are a lot of political answer but
let's not focus on that I think the one
answer is home transactions are risky
for both buyers and sellers their large
transaction is significant part of the
your life savings and so this risk as I
sorry this risk implies complexity a
typical home and purchase purchase and
sales contract for a typical home is
about 10 plus pages when you have such a
complicated scenario you need somebody
hand-holding and that's where the cost
is almost ten percent so there are three
brokers typically involved in a home
transaction to realtors together charge
six percentage and there is a loan
broker or loan officer which are just
when a half percent and there are a
bunch of other fees so so if a bias pays
half a million you are going to get 450
in your pocket and why is this so
complicated so here is a typical
purchase and sale agreement you actually
when you sign a purchase and sale
agreement people who haven't purchased
and so at home here it how it goes you
sign a purchase and sale agreement and
then it says in 30 days we will close
the exhale you the buyer will give the
money to the seller and seller will give
the home to the buyer okay in that
purchase agreement that's one thing the
Bible gives the money to the seller and
Zelda will be home to the buyer but then
there is a bulk of the agreement is
about the transaction failure so every
time the chain can fail if you're you
bought bought a computer at costco you
didn't like it the transaction fees that
entire risk is taken by costco because
costco is a
large player it can average out that
risk but here both sides are individuals
nobody actually can take that risk so
this makes it very hard and complicated
who is going to take the risk of loan
being failing who is going to take the
risk of something will they die dot
being discovered or things like that so
typically you pay a good-faith deposit
also called earnest money or different
things in different geographies you pay
some money hey here's your twenty
thousand dollars and I will purchase
your breakup fee if I don't end up
buying this home in certain condition
you can keep my breakup fee but
practically it doesn't happen because if
the seller is trying to keep that
breakup fee they cannot solve the home
until they dissolve the dispute so
really that unless money should be
called dispute when every transaction
feels if the transaction fields for
known reasons money is typically given
to the buyers if the transaction fields
for the reason for which sellers could
have kept the money such a transaction
usually result in a dispute so what
happens in a competitive situation which
is right now in many markets like Bay
Area or even Seattle they are like if
you put a house there are certainly 10
points in possible buyers each one of
them buys you so if you allow
contingencies in such a case then what
could happen that the winner
intentionally bets i win the house and
then negotiate the price down because he
has a contingency so that means a
competitive situation you would not
allow the contingencies but if you don't
allow the contingencies then the risk
for the bias goes up significantly even
the cost of bidding goes up many buyers
will do pre-inspection that's like
somewhere between five hundred thousand
dollars depending on the size of the
house so the cost of bidding goes up
then many buyers just walk away so in
either situation you actually leave
money on the table so what fear does is
the businessman it actually led this
agreement which is the essentially
one page agreement about the house and
then the second agreement with the
transaction failure it inserts itself in
between so there is no time catching
failure agreement between the sellers
and the buyer it everything goes through
Farrah and this simplifies actually
everything so now the seller's
experience is straightforward so let
seller provides the home address
everything is free to the sellers all
these all the entire transaction then
Philip will run the typical due
diligence process whatever the typical
buyers run for and if the transaction
fields available comparable compensate
the sellers and seller is free to sell
it to another buyer here is the bios
experience so this is a home on sale on
Farah as you can see you can find all
the due diligence documents uninfluenced
by this other the other they are done by
Farah and you can see whatever you want
to see so this is a new house the
otherwise say offer button here so you
best the offer button make whatever bed
you want to make since everything is
here the only thing you have to decide
is the number are you willing to pay
whatever money five hundred thousand
dollars just you press the button type
500,000 and your offer is submitted
within 30 seconds now here is the change
in business model there are few
innovation here bunnies when buyers and
seller agree on a price at that point
Bayern space half a percentage to Farrah
that's a fair a platform fee there was
no other fee there is no other path to
the seller or buyer now since the body's
paying this fee this is completely non
refundable that represents the
commitment from the buyer so there is no
1s money so remember we shot that the
transaction failure between buyers and
sellers and inserted Farrah in between
that's all very enjoyed in between there
is no unless money and the
after that according to the purchase and
sale agreement in within 30 days bio
space the purchase price and seller
gives the home like do you check the
tires we currently do not and we have
seen we will do it when we see in the
data the buyers because it is a
non-refundable half percent buyers are
actually self cailli discipline
themselves we keep the point five except
for the reasons which we provide if it
fails let's say we have done the pre
appraisal if your loan is declined
because the house was not as much as you
thought it is then you will get this out
person but if you fail the transaction
because you lost your job well that's
your problem you should have a job lost
insurance so we only cover the risk
which is within the transaction see
something breaks in the house is for
something between those 30 days if
something breaks the house so that then
this L is liable then we well in that
case we will defend the money to the
buyer so we will have a basically object
if this all the compensation to the
buyer come from us all the company's
compensation to the seller comes from us
for any kind of transaction failure and
there are scenarios where we will be
actually issuing compensation to both at
the same time
so we have turned on this platform we
have done two transactions we had done
five manually without before building
this platform and into transaction we
have served headed and 20 buyers and
guarded feedback from them
so conceptually now okay I need to say
that so you can actually show the
working of the linkage principle here
that if the inspection reports are up
front you can show that the conceptual
it deep seller is going to make more
money it's going to capture more buyers
and each buyer would be feeling less
risk and will be willing to pay offer
more money well but conceptually think
of a purchase and sale agreement as a
American call option 30 days American
call option so when you sign a purchase
and sale agreement the novel by this
home for a half-million-dollar by
certain date that's an American call
option you if you don't buy it then you
lose the premium the up person you paid
and this half percent is the time value
because it's typically in most
geographers it's the end of the place ok
so this concept actually allows so we
have doing just implemented one version
of it but it allows the market to be
more liquid suppose you are driving here
and you see this home listed for I don't
know the price is in beta but it's a two
million dollars and you think oh jeez it
should be cheaper it's not going to
solve you should be 1.5 currently you
don't have any way to provide that
feedback to the market because you want
anyway not willing was buying it and you
are not buying it so typically this
feedback that price is over price comes
much lower with the seller will be after
34 weeks if there is no interest will
realize that oh maybe I'm I should
decrease the price by another hundred K
and over like the several months that
the price will come right and the home
will sell but if you treat this contact
as a options then it's conceptually
possible for you to provide that
feedback to the market by actually
buying a put option on the house okay so
currently actually the there is no way
but this this this allows you to do
this allows you to basically enrich and
make this marketplace feature for the
home transaction for each home and there
are local investors who are always
interested in in in homes if being real
estate there's a lot of interest they
are so they can use it so conclusion
which will we didn't see variety of
business model I skipped a number of
them saw variety of and it's currently
considered mostly as an art you just
throw something on the yeah and blank
paper and wish that something comes out
if it comes out you think that you are
smart you are always knew this was the
right thing and if it doesn't come out
okay too bad so but I think there is a
scope of making this as towards little
bit more signs so there are number of
concepts one can starts analyzing them
and in particular when I was in
Microsoft I have a number of situation
remember so live search the one of the
brilliant idea many of Microsoft is hard
is that let's convert into a cost per
acquisition rather than cost per click
and there was a lot of support lot of
outside consultancy and at that point I
did not know this theorem but I still
oppose that cost per acquisition on the
only following ground that if it's a
cost per acquisition your advertisers
are not taking any risk so when you are
seeking that when should I show your ad
should then flour add be shown to
somebody who is looking for a car the
flowers LOL sure so the set of keywords
will be humongous by for everybody if
it's a cost by question there is no harm
in including that was the basically the
only reason then people say okay but we
can do much in learning we can prevent
all those things possibly it can be done
today but possibly it wasn't nobody
could do it that point
and I'm glad being dropped d it was it
used to be called live search it dropped
the cost per acquisition angle but they
still certain segments where cost per
acquisition could be interesting when I
advertise on Google from Farrah we had a
significant marketing budget but we when
we advertise on Google we think that
it's so dumb for Google to asking all
this information because Google have far
more data than we do have the entire
paradigm of keywords and keyword bidding
it seems so outdated so I took the part
of the budget from google and hired a
person to help me do that that money we
should never have gone to outside google
is now going outside google so there are
scenarios where if you start let's say
for pisa there might be a good pisa
joint here but that guy only didn't know
how to make best pisa he doesn't know
how to bait on google so all that
bidding on google will happen from
dominos papa zones and everything and
the people don't get to see that pisa
joint ad so that's all and any questions
your question
alright thanks Mike thank you